[Música]
en méxico se mata y se agrede a
periodistas y personas defensoras porque
se puede porque quienes los agreden y
quienes los matan jamás pisan la cárcel
porque además a muchos de nosotros no
nos importa que los agredan y que los
maten tan solo en el gobierno de enrique
peña nieto- hubo más de mil agresiones a
la prensa
106 defensores de derechos humanos
fueron asesinados extrajudicialmente y
81 defensores y defensoras están
desaparecidos y además de todo esto
todos los días nos tenemos que enfrentar
al descrédito y lo digo porque yo soy
periodista y defensora de derechos
humanos
nos desacredita el gobierno nos
desacreditan las empresas pero también
nos desacredita la ciudadanía
nos dicen que somos defensores de
criminales porque sacamos de la cárcel a
gente inocente y a los periodistas nos
dicen vendidos cuando la gran mayoría de
los periodistas en este país jamás han
recibido un soborno
qué hacemos los periodistas qué hacemos
los defensores de derechos humanos pues
bueno seguramente recordarán un
reportaje muy famoso del equipo de
investigación de carmen aristegui que se
llamó la casa blanca donde nuestro
presidente enrique peña nieto recibió
una casa de uno de los contratistas al
que más le otorgó obras en el estado de
mexico y después cuando fue presidente
de no ser por ese equipo valiente de
periodistas no nos hubiéramos enterado
que nuestro presidente en un país
democrático estaba recibiendo soborno de
un dvd una de las personas que trabajó
para él y que pasó los periodistas
fueron despedidos del espacio
también deberán de conocer o supongo que
conocen un caso llamado la estafa
maestra donde un grupo chiquito una
redacción pequeñita de reporteros de un
medio que se llama animal político
desencadenó una maraña de corrupción
donde nuestros políticos se robaron
miles de millones
y qué decir del trabajo de una
periodista de chihuahua llamada
miroslava breach que nos mostró como el
gobierno de chihuahua tenía nexos con el
crimen organizado a miroslaw a eso le
costó la vida a menos lava la mataron y
entonces la versión en las personas
defensoras de derechos humanos tampoco
es muy distinta a ella
qué hacemos las personas defensoras de
derechos humanos bueno
hay un caso de un grupo de mujeres
defensoras de derechos humanos en
veracruz pero también hay en todo el
país como ellas que al ver que las
autoridades no hacía absolutamente nada
por encontrar a sus hijos e hijas que
tenían años y meses desaparecidos ellas
mismas empezaron a organizar y ellas
mismas empezaron a buscar a sus hijos e
hijas desaparecidas y que pasó igual que
las rastreadoras en sinaloa encontraron
cadáveres una fosa encontraron en
veracruz con más de 100 restos humanos
fueron ellas no las autoridades ellas
son nuestras defensoras de derechos
humanos a las que nosotros señalamos con
que ayudan a los criminales hay otro
caso en el estado de mexico de un
defensor de derechos humanos que fue
detenido solamente por defender su
tierra por defender lo único que tenía
el territorio donde él su familia y su
comunidad vivían
a nacho del valle estuvo casi cuatro
años en una prisión de máxima seguridad
donde lo torturaron y lo tuvieron aparte
de toda la población una persona un
campesino indígena que solamente estaba
defendiendo su territorio le pusieron
una pena de casi cien años de cárcel
cuando vemos casos en este país como los
de un gobernador recientemente donde por
robarse la mitad del presupuesto de
veracruz le dan nueve años de cárcel
esto pasa en nuestro país porque
nosotros lo permitimos porque no nos
enteramos o no nos importa que esas
personas estén dando su vida estén dando
todo su tiempo por los demás porque
además eso hacen los periodistas eso
hacen los defensores de derechos humanos
en este país porque es muy difícil ir
contra la corriente
entonces justo nosotros desde la
organización donde trabajo que se llama
cencos nos dimos cuenta que a lo mejor
el problema estaba en nosotros que no
habíamos sabido explicarle a la gente
cuál era nuestro trabajo y por eso no
salían hordas de personas a la calle a
defendernos cuando mataban a alguien lo
agredían a alguien y creamos una campaña
que se llama voces libres que justamente
lo que explica es eso que hacemos y por
qué lo hacemos y también busca que
ustedes empiecen a pensar un poquito si
realmente hacen bien al señalarlos al
decirnos prensa vendida cuando nos ven
en la calle a decirnos que defendemos
criminales
este es un problema que va mucho más
allá de nuestras manos
y entonces simplemente nosotros nos
dimos a la tarea de explicarle a la
gente un poco de lo que hacemos porque
creemos que en este país si de por si el
trabajo de las y los periodistas y de
las personas defensoras de derechos
humanos es importante en todos lados en
un país yo no sé si usted se han visto
las noticias pero aquí en méxico tenemos
más de 37 mil personas desaparecidas 37
mil personas que las está buscando
alguien y entre el sexenio de felipe
calderón y enrique peña nieto- han
matado a casi 250.000 personas eso es
tres estadios azteca o 25 auditorios
nacionales imagínense 25 auditorios
nacionales llenos de cadáveres eso es lo
que pasa en nuestro país
y nosotros no nos estamos dando cuenta o
queremos hacer como que no nos damos
cuenta
pero esa gente esos periodistas y sus
defensores de derechos humanos lo están
haciendo por nosotros porque el día que
ustedes necesiten ayuda que para cómo
vamos cada familia en este país va a
tener una persona desaparecida van a
tener a alguien que le extienda la mano
porque esa gente está dando su vida por
los demás entonces lo único que les pido
es que pensemos un poco si estamos
dispuestos a dejar pasar que a una
defensora como marisela escobedo en
chihuahua la hayan matado nada más
porque exigía justicia sobre el
asesinato de su hija
primero mataron a su hija y ella exigir
justicia por su hija la mataron a ella o
que a uno de los periodistas más
reconocidos de este país
javier valdez lo hayan asesinado a plena
luz del día en culiacán sinaloa por
mostrarnos lo que hace el crimen
organizado en nuestra sociedad
a los periodistas y a las personas
defensoras de derechos humanos en méxico
se les asesina porque nosotros los
permitimos también
al nosotros señalarlos criminalizarlos y
no hacer nada al respecto estamos siendo
parte de eso y le estamos haciendo el
juego al gobierno a los grandes
empresarios que solamente buscan
callarnos o asesinar
ellos y ellas
son defensoras de derechos humanos que
están trabajando desde sus comunidades
ellos y ellas son periodistas que siguen
informando en todos sus espacios
ellos y ellas todavía no están muertos
así que les pido por favor que exijan
como sociedad voces libres que además
exigen que no se les agredan y que
exijan que no se les hace cine
gracias
[Aplausos]